a big move by the Trump administration
its strongest message yet for
jurisdictions that provide safe haven to
illegal immigrants Attorney General Jeff
Sessions announcing a lawsuit today
against the sanctuary state of
California from its capital Sacramento
California we have a problem the
California Legislature has enacted a
number of laws designed to intentionally
obstruct the work of our sworn
immigration officers that's why the
Department filed a suit against the
state of California to invalidate these
unjust laws and to immediately freeze
their effect I fundamentally believe at
my core that we should not further
endanger the lives of those who risk
everything for us because some officials
want to violate the law in promoting an
agenda that the American people reject
session specifically called out the
mayor who warned illegals last month
that the feds were coming the mayor of
Oakland has actively has been actively
seeking to help illegal aliens avoid
apprehension by ice so here's my message
to mayor shel
how dare you how dare you needlessly
endanger the lives of our law
enforcement officers to promote a
radical open borders agenda California's
governor responding with some fire of
his own this is really unprecedented for
the chief law enforcement of the United
States to come out to California and act
more like Fox News than a law
enforcement officer this is a political
stunt and it's not about the truth it's
not about protecting our state it's
about dividing America oh no you didn't
all right the state's getting a visit
from President Trump next week as well
okay so let's go California shall we
Greg I was triggered by him mr. Brown I
believe there should be a sanctuary City
for Fox News an entire city just like
airports for CNN entire cities where all
you can listen to is Fox News in
yeah that's a true sanctuary city in
liberal City why not create cities for
that that's the problem with this whole
story that there with the mayor of
Oakland three words that make me giggle
if you follow the law and you're
breaking the law you realize that this
could easily be reversed people can do
this to you too if you believe that this
law isn't worth following then somebody
else can do that to you for example a
sanctuary City for the unborn I mean the
media would go apoplectic if you said
here's a city where we will not perform
any abortions at all that would not
happen that would not happen but here
you can do that because you agree with
this law and I think what these battles
are designed to are designed for is to
create celebrities right if you stand up
against evil Trump you're gonna become
famous especially when you're the mayor
of Oakland which is like you don't have
any achievements behind you when you're
the mayor of Oakland so become famous by
standing up the evil Trump that's her
achievement mm-hmm all right Dana what
do you make of this I mean obviously
it's symbolic he's going straight to
sort of the root of the problem making
an appearance they're talking about this
and it's been quite widespread in terms
of the criticism of California San
Francisco in particular as a safe haven
for illegals I think it's an interesting
strategy and possibly a really good one
for the federal government because
they're at this point they're on offense
and the state is going to be on defense
previously you had sort of always been
like the feds we're on their heels well
now by filing this lawsuit the state is
going to have to show up and try to
defend themselves on these cases and I
think I don't I don't not a lawyer but I
think the Supremacy Clause that the
Constitution is going to bear out but we
know that the courts have been all over
the place on this so I think it's this
is actually a probably a useful exercise
for us to find out okay where is the law
actually on it on a political side of
things everyone gets to rally so that
Jerry Brown loved it today and everyone
the Democrats will love this today
president Trump's people will have loved
what Jeff Sessions did and then they're
gonna get excited because the president
will be there next week and so it's
setting up for like High Noon at the
border the last thing I would say is I'm
curious about the point of this mayor
and in the legal point about her
tipping off her citizens that ice the
ice rate is coming I don't know if it's
illegal but it doesn't have to be
illegal for it to sound wrong okay like
that that just sounds like the wrong
thing to do and if it was like a if she
was giving a heads up to a drug lord
that the cops are coming and there's
gonna be a bust
that would be obstruction because she's
trying to help out the drug lord this
one I don't I don't know where this
would actually end up but it does feel
like it's the wrong thing to do okay
Jesse sessions should throw the book at
this mayor because if this happens once
and it's allowed then everyone's gonna
do it like you said these many
celebrities I'm glad sessions woke up I
haven't heard from in a while this is
good I think governor Moonbeam is gonna
go down here the law is not on his side
his state is basically preventing the
federal government from conducting raids
and doing their jobs they just did a
raid the other day I mean look at some
of these nasty people
232 illegals arrested a hundred and
eighty of them convicted criminals and
look at some of the crimes serious
offenses child sex crimes weapons
charges assault some of them have been
back and forth over the border numerous
times so these aren't good people these
aren't just like regular farm workers
that are trying to make a living these
are bad hombres so keeping it criminals
in cities is dangerous and dumb a
kindergartener can understand that logic
I don't understand why the Democrats
don't get that states have clashed over
issues for years I mean over over pot
over marriage over voter ID with the
federal government now it's over
immigration the difference here it's
about public safety and let's just
pretend something Juan if that some
local gun dealer wasn't complying with
the federal background checks when they
sold weapons they say you know I don't
agree with that I don't like the
database deal with the FBI I'm not even
gonna check it and I'm not going to
cooperate it's the same kind of thing
it's dangerous the Democrats at least
should admit that they're Pro open
borders and Pro illegal immigration
because everybody would eventually know
I see well that's very different
viewpoints but those in purple ties it's
bad hombre like is it Cinco de Meyer
maybe you in front can have
tacos from them I just think this is so
absurd in the first place the mayor of
Oakland is not getting in the way of the
law she's not stopping them from
conducting mere raids not at all who
tipped them off and in fact no knows
what she did was she informally learned
that these raids were coming and to deal
with the high level of anxiety right now
in the immigrant community and
specifically oh these are rapists are
getting anxious oh yeah thinking up for
I tell you what let's have the American
rapist let's get American rapist off
we're doing okay but here you have a
situation where there are three things
at stake according to Xavier Becerra
who's the Attorney General of California
he says that you're not going to allow
cops to ask people about citizenship so
it's not like papers please if you stop
somebody in a stoplight no you can't
just start asking people at - no
workplace raids without a subpoena or a
warrant and finally no contract with
for-profit organizations that come in
and grab people and hold them for the
feds this is not interfering with the
federal government not interfering with
ice this is simply saying that local
money and local authority understands
that as Jesse said this is a public
safety issue it is and you want the
immigrants in your state in your city to
cooperate with police and not be afraid
you're not they're going to be deported
for humping a Donna morally that never
happens let me just snitched allow me to
make my larger point on this which is
larger point I think that this is a
distract I think one sessions who I'm
surprised that you're putting down
Trump's Attorney General but that's okay
I just haven't heard a lot for something
maybe he's appeasing President Trump and
setting up for his visit next week
because he feels like maybe they know I
do but I think maybe he right now is
pushing this suit because that's the
news of the day the suit Dana the second
thing I'd say is maybe he doesn't want
people to focus on why his wife got into
this country and her so-called Einstein
exception Einstein really she's an
Einstein you know think she's smart
she's a woman how did her parents get in
your old chain migration I thought he
hated shame but not when it's him not
when it is Melania qualifies for
merit-based I would say merit there
still isn't any credible statistics that
talk about how such this issue affects
cooperation with police at least I
haven't seen it I've been looking for it
the one thing when you say it said like
when you said I'm not a lawyer and where
is the law on this the real winner is
and all this stuff are lawyers because
every issue that we talk about it always
goes back to lawyers and cases and going
to court and it really is getting boring
for me but I want to lead me to my next
point where is this going actually is
this something that's worth fighting or
dying for to violate the law to allow
symbolic or real sanctuary for illegal
aliens of which Jesse points out the
ones that are being arrested are
criminals is this something that you are
willing to provide and die for is this
like this is do you think this is as big
as a fight against slavery or for civil
rights or for with a woman's right to
vote do you actually believe that that
you would rather put our country's laws
for the sake of illegal immigrants in
which some of them are actually criminal
Jordan you should go check the numbers
on this because my parents not only
support the dreamers they support the
idea that the people who have been here
that 11 million 11 million isolation
won't be allowed I support the dreamers
we're not talking about very very
different group let's please distinguish
between the dreamers and people who are
criminal predators the argument one you
use whenever we talk about radical Islam
and you accuse us of tainting all of
Islam yeah you're doing that no yes you
are
we talk about saying the Kimberly was
all the people who are here illegally
and I hope you hear this Jesse are not
criminals terrorists that's the argument
that we are about God fearing people
law-abiding people that come into this
country from other countries
and they get obtained a citizenship law
like my father came in from Ireland and
served in the military okay then my
mother moved over to my wedding in
Puerto Rico to San Francisco okay worked
hard worked jobs in the city worked as a
teacher did the whole thing they weren't
trying to violate any laws they weren't
committing any crimes so you know
there's a healthy interest believe me
I'm part of the Latino community of
which I am one of the members to make
sure that the laws are upheld in this
country that is the right thing to do to
be law-abiding and respectful of those
that want to come in you can still have
an open policy while respecting the laws
on the bus you have the two best parades
know the best ice agents at the parade
though oh my god Debbie water in the
crowd